die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen ihnen allen an meiner Seite
ist rudizane für den Sport hallo schönen
guten Abend und das sind die Themen von
heute
Balanceakt in der Golfregion
Bundeskanzler Scholz will mit mehreren
arabischen Staaten neue
energiepartnerschaften schließen aber
auch heikle Themen ansprechen
abstimmen unter Druck bei den
scheinreferenten in den besetzten
Ukraine Gebieten gibt es Hinweise auf
erzwungene Stimmabgaben
und eine Tennislegende tritt ab nach
einem letzten Doppel in London hat Roger
Federer seine einzigartige Karriere
beendet
[Musik]
in Zeiten knapper Energie werden Länder
zu Partnern um die man in den letzten
Jahren eher einen Bogen machte unter
anderem wegen der Menschenrechtslage
dort und so verbringt der Bundeskanzler
sein Wochenende in den Golfstaaten
mitgereist ist eine große
Wirtschaftsdelegation
es geht nach Katar in die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate und gleich zu Beginn
nach Saudi Arabien und schon die erste
Station hatte es in sich in der
Hafenstadt didda traf Scholz den
Kronprinzen Mohammad in Salman einen
Mann der für den brutalen Mord am
Journalisten Jamaika verantwortlich
gemacht wird Andreas Kühnast und Andrea
Meuser berichten
Handschlag oder nicht wie würde die
Begrüßung zwischen dem saudischen
Kronprinzen Mohammed Gin Salman und
Bundeskanzler Scholz verlaufen es wurde
ein Handschlag und sogar ein äußerst
freundlicher vier Jahre lang galten die
Beziehungen zwischen Deutschland und
Saudi-Arabien als zerrüttet der Mord
dann Jamaika schogi der Krieg im Jemen
und auch die Menschenrechtslage all das
lastete auf den Beziehungen all das hat
sich nicht geändert aber deutschland
sieht sich vor der Notwendigkeit sich
auf dem Energiemarkt nach neuen Partnern
umzuschauen wir haben hier auch
gesprochen über die Fragen die uns für
die Zukunft miteinander bewegen werden
das gilt insbesondere für die
Weiterentwicklung
unserer Volkswirtschaften im Hinblick
auf eine CO2-neutrale Zukunft heute
importieren wir fossile Ressourcen auch
aus Saudi-Arabien für die Zukunft wird
es aber auch darum gehen dass wir im
großen Ausmaß Möglichkeiten schaffen
Wasserstoff in Deutschland einzusetzen
der hier und auch an anderen Stellen
eingestellt wird die Reise solle aber
keine reine energie-einkaufstour werden
hatte Scholz vor seiner Abreise noch
erklärt und versichert er werde alle
sensiblen Bereiche ansprechen wir haben
alle Fragen besprochen die sich um
Fragen von Bürger und Menschenrechten
drehen das gehört sich so und da können
sie von ausgehen dass nichts
unbesprochen geblieben ist begleitet
wird der Kanzler von einer hochkarätigen
Wirtschaftsdelegation Energie gegen
Technologie so könnte ein möglicher Deal
lauten am Abend geht die Reise des
Kanzlers weiter zunächst in die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate und dann
nach Katar auch das keine einfachen
Begegnungen
vor seinem Abflug hat der Bundeskanzler
in seiner wöchentlichen Videobotschaft
versprochen dass jetzt schnell die
geplanten Entlastungen kommen für
Privathaushalte und für Unternehmen doch
diese staatliche Unterstützung reiche
längst nicht aus kritisieren opposition
und Gewerkschaften und fordern eine
gaspreisbremse Angela Eppert hat Details
im Gas zu sparen dreht Julia
Drosselmeier schon mal Ihre Heizung
runter die alleinerziehende Mutter aus
Wiesbaden hat vor den Stadtwerken
erfahren dass sie statt 93 Euro Abschlag
im Monat künftig 200 ein Euro zahlen
muss mehr als das Doppelte das hat mich
natürlich schockiert und
trotzdem ich kann nichts tun ich kann
jetzt nur hoffen dass ich vielleicht
irgendwie
energieeinspare und nicht so viel
verbrauche die deftigen Preiserhöhungen
für viele nicht zu bezahlen in
Deutschland wird deswegen über einen
gaspreisdeckel diskutiert für eine
Grundmenge an Erdgas würde der Preis für
die Verbraucher gesenkt finanziert durch
den Staat wer dann aber mehr Energie als
der Durchschnitt verbraucht muss dafür
den höheren Marktpreis bezahlen
gefordert wird der gaspreisdeckel von
der Union den linken von Gewerkschaften
Ökonomen und Sozialverbänden das
wichtigste ist jetzt wirklich dass es
systematische Lösungen gibt für die
Menschen denn viele können Ihre Kosten
überhaupt nicht mehr tragen wissen nicht
was passiert wenn Sie um eine vielfach
höhere Strom oder Gasrechnung kriegen
und deswegen braucht es jetzt ein
Eingriff in den Markt auf der anderen
Seite muss so ein gaspreisdeckel
finanziert werden das könnten Kosten in
Milliardenhöhe bedeuten zu stemmen vom
Staat
jetzt nicht als die adäquate Lösung an
weil eben alle Verbraucher auch die
Wohlhabenden Haushalte dadurch
begünstigt werden ist dadurch sehr sehr
teuer werden wird für den Staat es wäre
besser wenn die wirklich Bedürftigen
Haushalte gezielt durch pauschale
Transfers dann unterstützt werden
Deckel oder gezielte finanzielle
Unterstützung Julia Drosselmeier ist es
egal hauptsache ihr Gas bleibt bezahlbar
Energiekrise und Inflation könnten auch
die innere Sicherheit in Deutschland
gefährden so steht es in einem internen
Papier des Bundeskriminalamts aus dem
der Tagesspiegel zitiert demnach
versuchten bestimmte Kreise die
derzeitige Krisenlage für sich zu nutzen
das BKA rechnet mit einer ähnlichen Lage
wie bei den Protesten gegen die
corona-maßnahmen
seit vier Tagen werden in Russland
Reservisten für den Krieg in der Ukraine
eingezogen heute unterschrieb Präsident
Putin ein Gesetz zur Verschärfung der
Strafen für Soldaten die desertieren
oder kapitulieren ihnen drohen jetzt bis
zu zehn Jahre Haft in den russisch
besetzten Gebieten in der Ukraine gehen
die scheinabstimmungen über einen
Beitritt zu Russland weiter Franziska
von tiesenhausen berichtet
sie wollen nur noch raus aus den
besetzten Gebieten in der Region
saporicia haben es einige wenige bis an
die Grenze zum Ukrainisch kontrollierten
Teil geschafft
Mobilisierung alle werden eingezogen und
müssen kämpfen
von meinen Bekannten ist niemand damit
einverstanden viele haben sich auf den
Weg gemacht wollen nichts damit zu tun
haben
es sind wohl auch bilder wie diese aus
sozialen Netzwerken die die Menschen zur
Flucht treiben sie sollen
Wahlhelferinnen in Begleitung
bewaffneter Soldaten zeigen die von Tür
zu Tür gehen und die Stimmabgabe
überwachen
unabhängig überprüfen lassen sich die
Aufnahmen nicht
die US-Regierung droht mit weiteren
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland und
verurteilt die geplanten Annexionen
die Vereinigten Staaten werden diese
Gebiete niemals als etwas anderes als
Teil der Ukraine anerkennen gemeinsam
mit unseren Partnern auf der ganzen Welt
weisen wir die wie auch immer zustande
gekommenen Ergebnisse zurück die
Russland verkünden wird
seit gestern lässt Russland in diesen
vier Gebieten scheinreferenten über den
Beitritt zur Russischen Föderation
abhalten obwohl die Abstimmungen noch
bis Dienstag laufen werden ukrainischen
Angaben zur Folge bereits die ersten
Männer in die russische Armee einberufen
kriminelle Mobilisierung die Russland in
Teilen unseres Landes durchführt ist
nicht nur ein Verstoß gegen das
Völkerrecht und gegen ukrainisches recht
es ist auch ein Verbrechen gegen die
Rechte einzelner Menschen und gegen
unser Volk
rote
und in Russland selbst halten die
Proteste gegen die teilmobilisierung an
in Moskau und anderen Städten wurden
auch heute wieder Demonstranten
festgenommen
in Moskau wie massiv waren heute diese
Proteste
also in Moskau hatten die Proteste gar
keine Chance sich zu entfalten die
Sicherheitskräfte sind massiv gegen die
Demonstranten vorgegangen schon vor
Beginn der eigentlichen Veranstaltung
gab es hier einige Festnahmen 300 allein
in Moskau 700 im ganzen Land das Wetter
wird viele abgeschreckt heute haben hier
in Moskau den ganzen Tag Dauerregen und
Berichte die auch kursieren in den
Social Media Kanälen dass Demonstranten
hier an diesen nicht genehmigten
Protesten teilnehmen noch auf dem
Polizeirevier ihren Einberufungsbescheid
bekommen haben also das soll auch
abschreckende Wirkung haben ansonsten
häufen sich auch die Berichte über
Beschwerden dass bei der Einberufung
insgesamt nicht alles nach Plan läuft es
gibt Berichte dass Männer eingezogen
werden die gar nicht eigentlich zum
skizzierten Personenkreis gehören also
da gibt es wohl noch viel
Optimierungsbedarf und die Kritik wächst
vielen Dank nach Moskau Christiansen
auch die Proteste in Iran verschärfen
sich alleine im Norden gab es mal aus
700 Festnahmen mindestens 35 Menschen
wurden nach offiziellen Angaben getötet
auch heute zeigten die Menschen in
Teheran und vielen anderen Städten ihre
Wut auf das mularegime mit seiner
sittenstränge ausgelöst wurden die
Unruhen durch den ungeklärten Tod von
Massa Amini die Sittenpolizei hatte die
22-Jährige festgenommen weil sie ihr
Kopftuch angeblich in nicht korrekter
Weise getragen hatte
nach Italien dort wird morgen ein neues
Parlament gewählt und ein Triumph der
rechtsnationalen scheint ziemlich sicher
dann könnte sie erste
Ministerpräsidentin Italiens werden
Giorgio Georgia Meloni die 45-Jährige
liegt mit ihrer
rechtsaußenparteivatelli d'Italia in den
Umfragen Form zusammen mit der leger von
Matthäus Salvini und der Forza Italia
von Silvio Berlusconi reicht es
voraussichtlich für die Mehrheit das
Motto des Trios mehr Italien weniger
Europa Andreas Postel berichtet
auch auf diesen außergewöhnlich kurzen
Wahlkampf in Italien folgt traditionell
der jonata del Silencio ein Tag der
Stille vor der Parlamentswahl und diese
scheint auch nötig denn viele wissen
noch nicht ob und wen sie wählen sollen
konopa es fällt mir diesmal sehr schwer
aber ich werde wählen gehen
sie im Wahlkampf Dinge die sie danach
nicht einhalten
links oder rechts Zuverlässigkeit gibt
es nicht
zum Wahlkampfabschluss demonstriert das
mit rechtsbündnis den Schulterschluss
trotz aller Bekundungen Italien bleibe
mit ihnen ein verlässlicher Partner
lassen Äußerungen immer wieder daran
zweifeln für Irritationen sorgte Silvio
Berlusconi der russische Präsident sei
doch in den ukrainekrieg gedrängt worden
und Putin Fan Matthäus Salvini will die
EU-Sanktionen gegen Russland am liebsten
abschaffen Georgia Meloni die
Spitzenkandidatin der
Nationalkonservativen fratelli d'Italia
mit faschistischen Wurzeln führt die
Umfragen an
es heißt man mache sich in Europa Sorgen
wegen Meloni aber was wird passieren was
passieren wird ist dass der Spaß vorbei
ist dass Italien seine nationalen
Interessen verteidigen wird
in den Umfragen zweitstärkste Kraft
Sozialdemokrat in Rico letter er
versteht sich nach dem Scheitern der
Regierung Draghi als Garant für
Stabilität und sozialen Ausgleich ihm
gelang es allerdings nicht ein linkes
Wahlbündnis zu schmieden mit der
linkspopulistischen fünf-sterne-bewegung
die scheint besonders im Süden mit
sozialen Versprechungen aufzuholen
wer auch immer die nächste Regierung in
Italien stellt wird kaum
Handlungsspielraum für Experimente haben
Krieg Energiekrise Staatsverschuldung
Italien ist dringend auf die
eu-milliarden aus Brüssel angewiesen und
die wiederum sind an konkrete
Reformschritte gebunden die große Zahl
der unentschlossenen und deren
Wahlbeteiligung wird mitentscheiden ob
und wie stark Italien nach rechts rückt
morgen geht die bedeutendste deutsche
Kunstausstellung zu Ende die Dokumenta
in Kassel diese 15 Dokumente hat
polarisiert wie keine zuvor
beherrschendes Thema waren nicht die
ausgestellten Werke sondern die
Antisemitismus-Vorwürfe gegen die
Ausstellungsmacher die Begeisterung über
neue Zugänge zur Kunst ging dabei fast
unter Peter Theissen zieht nach 100
Tagen Bilanz
sie startete mit großen Ambitionen aus
aller Welt sollten Künstler kollektive
zur Dokumenta kommen dieses aus Berlin
sogar mit einem Boot und nachhaltigem
Antrieb das kuratierende
Künstlerkollektiv hohen grupa erhob
lumbung zum Leitmotiv indonesisch für
etwas gemeinschaftlich genutztes weg vom
Kunst Commerz alles sollen sich
gegenseitig helfen und voneinander
lernen Kunst als Prozess ich denke wenn
wir uns im Moment die Welt angucken geht
es nur gemeinsam und dazu sind einige
inspirierende Ideen hier das finde ich
gut das spannende war dass der globale
Süden im Vordergrund stand und nicht die
weisen alten Männer die individuell als
Künstler agieren doch die Perspektive
des globalen Südens sorgte für Skandale
ein großes Banner aus Indonesien mit
eindeutig antisemitischen Darstellungen
musste entfernt werden und auch danach
tauchten immer wieder antisemitische
oder israelkritische Motive auf wenn ein
semitische stroh-typ in diese Form
bekommen sie sind auf der Dokumente
nicht in Ordnung sie sind auch in der
sie sind auch in den globalen Süden in
den Tunesien aber auch in anderen
Ländern nicht in Ordnung und das muss
klar sein das kollektivprinzip sorgte
aber dafür dass nie jemand wirklich
verantwortlich war Forderungen wurden
laut die Dokumenta in Zukunft stärker zu
kontrollieren Widerspruch die
Risikobereitschaft der Dokumenta und das
ist das was sie in den vergangenen 70
Jahren ausgemacht hat wenn wir die
erhalten wollen dann müssen wir uns
einlassen auf eine möglichst
weitreichende Freiheit der
künstlerischen Leiter die Dokumenta war
in ihrer Geschichte oft umstritten doch
diesmal wurde sie in ihren Grundfesten
erschüttert übrigens das in Berlin
gestartete Künstlerkollektiv blieb auf
der Weser stecken und kann nie in Kassel
an
jetzt Fußball rudi war kein so schöner
Abend für die Nationalmannschaft aber
vielleicht auch ein Dämpfer zur rechten
Zeit 0:1 verliert die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft im nations
League Spiel gegen Ungarn und verpasst
den Gruppensieg und damit die Endrunde
für Bundestrainer haben sie Flick ist es
die erste Niederlage seiner Amtszeit und
das zwei Monate vor der WM Flick erfüllt
heute die Wünsche der großen und kleinen
Fans nachdem es gestern eins auf die
Mütze gab eine spielerisch und taktisch
völlig missratene WM-Generalprobe die in
Enttäuschung und Ernüchterung mündet die
Liste der Defizite wird länger und
länger wenig Mut wenig wenig Vertrauen
wenig Dynamik wenig Intensität viele
Fehler und diese Fehler nutzen
Siegtorschütze soloy und Ungarn eiskalt
aus defensive und offensive noch nicht
turniertauglich alarmierend so kurz vor
der WM vielleicht zur rechten Zeit
die Niederlage gekommen ist mir
natürlich lieber wenn es bei der WM ist
ohne den gesperrten Rüdiger und
verletzten Manager reisen sie nach
England fliegt rennt die Zeit davon 2
Monate vor der WM ist sein Team immer
noch in erfindungsphase
roger Federer hat seine Karriere beendet
letzte Auftritt im Doppel beim lasercup
in London an der Seite seines
Konkurrenten und Freundes Raphael Nadal
trotz einer Niederlage wird der
Schweizer überschwänglich gefeiert
Ellie Gouldings Abschiedslied für Roger
Federer falling for you in dich verliebt
große Gefühle in der Arena in London für
Federer und Doppelpartner Rafael Nadal
einer der größten im Tennis geht ein
Sympathieträger gefürchtet geschätzt
geliebt die Teams Europa und Rest der
Welt lassen den 20-maligen Grand Slam
Champion hochleben
es war ein wirklich schöner Tag ich habe
den Jungs hier gesagt dass ich glücklich
bin nicht traurig sportlich erleben
tausende von Zuschauern auch den ein
oder anderen magischen Federer Moment
zwischen Netz und Pfosten passt wirklich
nur ein Tennisball das Federer und
Natalie Doppel verloren haben neben
Sache es war eine perfekte reise ich
würde alles wieder genauso machen
mehrmals überwältigt ihn die Situation
unvergesslich die Momente danach mit
Fans Freunden Gegnern und mit den
wichtigsten Menschen seines Lebens
großartiger Mensch Liane Lippert aus
Friedrichshafen verpasst bei der
Straßenrad WM in Australien knapp das
Podium und wird vierte den
Weltmeistertitel sichert sich erneut die
Weltranglisten erste animek von fleuten
aus den Niederlanden die trotz eines
gebrochenen Ellbogens nicht zu schlagen
ist
wirklich bemerkenswert das war's können
wir nicht noch mal zu Roger Federer
zurück
Elton John ist aber auch ein guter hat
weltweit viele Fans ein besonderer hat
ihn jetzt nach Washington eingeladen ins
Weiße Haus US-Präsident beiden zeichnete
die Pop-Legende für ihr Engagement aus
und sagte Elton Johns Musik habe sein
Leben verändert
[Musik]
unter den 2000 Gästen waren übrigens
eine ganze Reihe von Pflegekräften und
Lehrern
fehlt noch das Wetter das bringt viele
Wolken auch mal längeren Regen und
kühler wird es auch noch die Details hat
gleich Katja Horne fahren Maria Slomka
begrüßt sie um viertel 11 im
heute-journal und wir sagen tschüss bis
morgen alles Gute ihnen und ein schönes
Wochenende noch
[Musik]
guten Abend Hurrikan fiona hat sich
inzwischen zu einem außer tropischen
orkanti verwandelt und als solches hat
es heute die Ostküste Kanadas erreicht
es wird von Wellenhöhen von 15 Metern
berichtet viel Wind und viel Regen Regen
fällt allerdings auch bei uns in Europa
vor allen Dingen hier im Mittelitalien
morgen können in Rom oder in Neapel 100
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen in
den Alpen Fällen etwas Schnee und bei
uns etwas Regen jetzt in der Nacht lässt
der Regen erstmal nach und an der Donau
oder auch in Schleswig-Holstein kann
sich mal Nebel bilden die Temperaturen
sinken an den Küsten von Nord- und
Ostsee auf 11 Grad 6 Grad sind es
Nordfriesland in den östlichen
Mittelgebirge und am Alpenrand dort
bleibt es dann morgen über Tag auch am
kühlsten mit nur 13 Grad 14 Grad sind es
im Sauerland sonst gibt es Werte um die
16 Grad etwas milder wird es in Berlin
Brandenburg und Sachsen mit 18 19 Grad
dort zeigt sich morgen Vormittag nämlich
noch häufiger die Sonne sonst ist es
meist stark bewölkt es fällt häufig
Regen es kann auch mal länger anhalten
regnen nachmittags sind hier in
Ostbayern noch einige Gewitter dabei im
Nordwesten ist es dagegen freundlicher
und die neue Woche wird immer
herbstsicher es gibt häufiger Regen und
es wird kühler guten Abend